we're in the middle durak we are any
gallery we've got some francis agra
francis bacon does commercial reality
come into this as a young I mean it is
reality your art has got a cell for the
artists to survive we have to make a
living you know it's a blog we have
these massive funds just lying around
for us this is my job you know what do
you get from being in Zurich does that
give you a different presence of mind
does that give different meaning about
painting it's bizarre me people would
look at me and think I'm on drugs if I
say this but it is definitely a huge
huge factor little things like the air
the freshness of the air the the way of
life the privacy how different is that I
mean New York is the commercial know of
dollars dollars dollars but it's just as
commercial here isn't it yeah I think so
but it's it's it is a different way in
which it is commercial it's very
understated you will always be the word
is the concept calm for young artists to
go yeah you know what I'm gonna develop
my own I'm gonna develop my own my own
concept of a paint where did that come
from because that's what you need
what is McWeeny bleep inside Macready
blue of five components of the blue
which this is the special unique blue
that goes into every paint in the heat
it goes into every bottle pigment on
from the Creedy room five different
components of blue which create this
which is an advanced where those
components are or is that no you know
you're allowed to ask me
you're going through a patenting process
it's a very hectic process I mean this
something is Payton painting it it could
take up to three to six years I don't I
don't like it that much I mean I like it
it's my painting but but I want more I
want a little bit more white spin it I
like that already just like that's
really bitter
I like it